Well, when I started my graduate work
in genetics the big question was
what on earth is this gene?
How can it do these amazing things
that it does? And it was a complete mystery.
That was the big question, that was the question that
attracted me to genetics and that made me want to spend my life
trying to get an answer or get part of the
answer. By that time, a lot was known about
how genes are transmitted in heredity
and some of the things that they control.
But nothing was known about the physical
chemical structure that was responsible for
what the gene could do. And it seemed very inaccessible
and very hard to get at. And that was the question
that was mostly on my mind. To find a way to work
that would help to decide what the gene
was like and how it could do what it was doing.
I was working with bacteria. Bacteria
had become a very good material to work with
in genetics, because in 1943 while I was a
graduate student, for the first time, it became clear
that bacteria had genes like other organisms.
Before that, the bacteriologists were telling us that
bacteria just change with the environment.
When it was established that they had
regular genes and they could be used for genetic
experiments, that's when I decided I wanted to work with
bacteria. I was just beginning the research for my PhD
and I had planned to do it with the fruit fly,
which was the standard organism in genetics
and a wonderful little bug.
And I was going to try to understand how
radiation induces mutation in fruit fly, Drosophila.
When I read that paper proving that bacteria
had genes, I really got excited and thought
that would be a wonderful material to work with.
I mean, they multiply every 20 minutes and you could
hold a billion of them in a little test tube.
And so just think how many generations
you could work with in very short time.
So, that's when my advisor at Columbia,
Professor Dobzhansky, saw how excited I was about
this new development using bacteria for genetics.
He suggested that I might want to do my PhD
research with E. coli instead of Drosophila.
And that's why he sent me to Cold Spring Harbor
for the summer. To learn how to work with bacteria.
Luria and Delbruck the ones who had discovered that
bacteria had genes and they were going to be
there in Cold Spring Harbor in that summer.
And so I did go and that was one of the
most fortunate events in my working life
that I've connected with Cold Spring Harbor.
Because it turns out, I actually stayed there for
11 years. I had a kind of beginner's luck,
I think. The very first experiment I did, I had
no idea what I was doing. The director at
the laboratory at Cold Spring Harbor handed me
a culture of E. coli in a test tube and he pointed
to an ultraviolet lamp, and said "Go. Induce mutations."
So I had to sort of feel my way as to how to work
with these bugs. I watched other people and saw
how they worked. And I started my very first experiment
and the first thing I needed to do was to decide
what does of ultraviolet light to use, because there were no
published information about that. So I was stabbing
in the dark at the first try. And in my first try
I overdid the dose, I used doses much too high
and the next day, when I looked at my
petri dishes, I found that I had put a million bacteria
on the surface of each of them. And the next day,
nobody grew. There was nothing on any of the plates.
Except one petri dish had four colonies
growing on it. So four bacteria out of a million
that I had put on that petri dish had somehow
survived this very high dose. And it occurred to me
that maybe those four were mutants resistant to radiation
because in Cold Spring Harbor at that point, there was
a lot of talk about resistance. Dr. Demerec was working on
resistance to penicillin, which had just been discovered.
And there was resistance to this, that, and the other that people
were working on. So I thought, why did they survive?
Just four bacteria out of millions?
And I cultured them and tested them
and sure enough, they could withstand at least 100x
more radiation, both ultraviolet light and later we found
x-rays, than the parent strain. It turned out
to be a clue to a whole new area that I was just starting
to work on. And it led me to understanding that ultraviolet
light does a lot more than just induce mutations.
It activates what we now know to be 43 genes, at least
43 different genes in E. coli that are quiet and
silent when the cell is healthy, but are suddenly
activated and start turning out their product when the
DNA is damaged by radiation or some other agents.
My first mutation sort of led me into
perceiving that this was going on.
And it was a discovery of what we call the SOS response
in E. coli, which implies that it's a life saving mechanism
which it is indeed. Because of the activities that are turned on
by these genes that are activated by the damage
promote the repair of the damage and the survival
of the cell in a variety of different ways.
And the survival of the population, actually.
And I think that my experience in Cold Spring Harbor
was what sort of softened me up to think in terms of repair
because one of the people I met at Cold Spring Harbor was
a scientist named Barbara McClintock, who won the Nobel Prize
in her 80s, I think. For the amazing work that she did
in genetics. It was a pleasure to get to know her and
one of the things that I remember best about being
at Cold Spring Harbor was the many times that I spent
in Barbara McClintock's laboratory, looking over her shoulder
and watching her work. When she was making her major
discovery, when she found that genes actually can
move from one location to another, this was very
revolutionary. We always thought that a chromosome
was very stable and genes stay put, but
she showed that they can jump and they can have
important effects when they do. At any rate, one of the things
that Barbara was working on, and she talked about this
at our meetings at Cold Spring Harbor, she was studying
how chromosomes join together when they're broken.
Because chromosomes can break as a result of
various treatments, and when they do, she noticed
that they come together very rapidly.
The broken ends join and she was very puzzled about
how that could work, but she did make a point of saying
that they could -- the broken ends could find each
other over a long distance through the very different
parts of the nucleus, they would sort of aim at each other.
There seemed to be a force that was bringing them together.
And since genes are in chromosomes
and chromosomes are being repaired
when they're broken, it seemed to me that there
must be some kind of molecular repair going on
inside the chromosome that would involve carrying the gene.
So I think that exposure to the way broken chromosomes
are repaired made me think in terms of repair when I
was considering what was happening in irradiated bacteria.
Before the DNA is damaged, let's say by radiation,
the DNA is quietly replicating itself, copying itself.
And when DNA is damaged by ultraviolet light,
for instance, which changes one of the elements
of the DNA and stops the replication, the enzymes that are
copying the DNA cannot get by that damaged spot.
So the whole thing stops. And that's lethal if nothing happens.
Because if the replication is stopped and there's nothing
that can restart it, that's the end of that cell.
But we learned later that E. coli and all cells
including human cells, have developed repair mechanisms
that can in various ways, take care of that damage and
get rid of it, one way or another. There are a number
of different ways to do it. And usually, they work very efficiently
and the damage just goes away and the replication
continues. And that happens, as I say, in a number of
ways. For instance, if you shine visible light on the
E. coli after it's been damaged by ultraviolet
that will take care of getting rid of the damage. The visible
light splits that lump that's sitting on the DNA
and makes it go away. So that's an immediate repair.
And then there's another repair mechanism
that's called the "cut and patch" mechanism.
Actually, excision repair. Which detects the damaged
spot, cuts one strand of the DNA on one side of the
damage, cuts on the other side, and thereby removes
a small piece of the DNA containing the damage.
And that leaves a gap, see, DNA has two strands,
so there's one strand that's still in tact and the other one has
a piece taken out of it by this cut and patch mechanism.
And another enzyme comes along and fills in
that patch, using the information on the other strand
to do it accurately. So that's another repair mechanism
that acts very quickly and that takes care of most of the
damage that happens. But sometimes, there's a kind of damage
that cannot be easily repaired by these mechanisms.
And that's when the SOS response happens.
So here you have damage sitting on the DNA
which the visible light couldn't help and the cut and patch
couldn't help for some reason, and then what happens is
the stalled replication, the place where the replication
has stopped, generates a signal that says "SOS!"
Basically. And then a number of things happen,
and I can't really describe them in great detail,
but the two strands of DNA come apart into a sort of
bubble and that's the signal for the SOS system
is single stranded DNA, which normally doesn't
occur in the happily replicating DNA. But the single strands
bubbling out cause another molecule to come and bind
those single strands. And that sets off a sequence
which leads to turning on 43 genes. You know,
there were a lot of people involved in that, and I haven't
mentioned all the people, but the SOS response was
a joint work. And this was a young man,
whose name was Miroslav Radman, he was a
postdoctoral fellow at Harvard and I had written a paper
in which I suggested that ultraviolet light was inducing
two different consequences in a similar way that seemed
as if they were being induced together. And Radman
a few years later, had linked to other ultraviolet effects
and suggested that they were both induced by the same
signal. And one of them was the same one that I had
linked, so we both linked A, I had linked it to B,
and he had linked it to C. And when we met, I guess it was
in 1972, he had just described his end of it. And
we met and we put together this observation that
I had linked two events that were caused by UV
and said that they were induced together, and he had
linked two others, and one of them was the common one.
So there we had three different ultraviolet
effects that we thought were induced in a common
way by a single signal. And that was really the beginning,
and by the way, Radman was the one who introduced
the term "SOS." And it was used in the sense of
the international distress signal. So in a way, our
putting together our two separate pieces of this
began the SOS response to be appreciated.
It was a great joy to be a part of the group that
was working on DNA repair. I mean, it was a small
international group, there must have been probably
I'd say 30-35 individual scientists and the group of
students around them and so on, who were trying
to understand how the DNA changes and how it's repaired
and all of that. And being part of that group was
one of the most joyful experiences I ever had
in science, because it was a group of people with a
very common set of goals and I sometimes hear
these days that there's a lot of competitiveness
in science. It doesn't ring a bell with the way it was
in my experience, at all. We shared our information,
we shared our strains, we cheered for each other
when somebody made an important discovery, and
it was a human experience that was extremely
satisfying. And when I look back at my work, that's a big part
of why I'm glad I did science.